but there are other countries that
do not like they what i would consider
play dirty like they will
kill your dog you know just just to mess
with you just to let that
just to let you know that they know who
you are
right you know they'll do things to make
you sick to make you leave to make it so
uncomfortable for you to be there
that you'll just go because i mean they
just don't want you there right they'll
do things to mess with you
um they'll they'll surveil you
like obviously so you know that you're
constantly being watched
you know intimidating you right so i
mean there's lots of different
tactics that intelligence agencies use
um
you know the the ones we think about are
the ones where everything's a secret
and nobody knows and everything's doing
everybody's doing things in the shadows
but then there's kind of the dirty side
where they do things overtly
just to harass you harass you
intimidate you there are
there are intelligence agencies that use
um
you know blackmail and manipulation
um which in in the cia's view is not
like that's not a functional way like
that is not sustainable
right like you're if you're blackmailing
somebody for intelligence
it's not really the best way to go like
that's not the best way to get
intelligence it's not sustainable that
something's going to happen you can't
keep that up maybe you could do it once
you know but if you're trying to build a
long-term intelligence relationship with
an asset
that's not the way to go but there are
plenty of countries who do it
you know doesn't the united states break
sort of international laws too
i mean don't they don't we break a lot
of laws that we just
say it's okay because we're the united
states well so does everybody
so all the countries do it um so be so
gathering
intelligence in like any country is
illegal in every country
um so to that extent yes
um you're definitely you know by
recruiting some you know
somebody to to spy on their country like
you're breaking the law but that's
that's the game right so like
that's like the gentleman's game right
like everybody knows it's happening
everybody knows they're doing it
everybody knows that you know
like in any given country like the brits
have spies there the americans have
spies there the french have spies there
the
you know the thais have spies there like
if there's an embassy or if there's a
forum presence or whatever like
there's spies there everybody knows it
and but that's the gentleman's game
right like
i like i see you you know you see us
okay yeah like if you're go you know be
good enough to keep yourself secret
you know that's that's for me like
that's the real
game of you know that's the proper
intelligence game i think
so what is in your opinion what is like
the overarching view of the united
states from
these other countries that you visited
so what is their perspective i'm sure
you spent a lot of time talking to a lot
of different people
yeah so um i can speak mostly for asia
and the perspective there is really
interesting because
the united states has a lot of influence
throughout asia
just historically from world war ii
but china is their actual neighbor and
china has a longer history
with all of the asian countries like
east asian southeast asian
and it's really impressive to see
the fine line that the like
asean basically countries walk right
like they want
they don't china's aggressive so they
don't really want to be
like under china's thumb but the united
states isn't going to step up in the way
that they want them to step up
all the time i know
obama did like an asia pivot
but that changes president the president
right like whatever the focus is
changes over time where china like that
is their
backyard so china is interested in
having control over those countries
through trade
having control of the waters for their
navy
so it's this really interesting dynamic
of
you know they like the united states
they see us as a power like a power for
good a power an
ally but china's sitting right there and
they have to
like they cannot ignore china like if
they had to choose
my bet would always be on china like if
they ever had to choose between
who they were gonna back because
america's far away
i think so i mean that's my from my
experience
because you know
so sometimes america goes through its
moods right sometimes america just
doesn't want to be involved
and they're like oh america's not going
to back us up this president
you know some like america is far away
so by the time it took us to
do anything like china is literally
sitting right there
and then you know the culture's a little
bit different like everything i was
saying about
you know you need to be able to put
yourself into the shoes of the ties of
the cambodians of the
malaysians right like has america done a
good enough job or diplomats doing a
good enough job of doing that to be able
to have those discussions
you know so
yeah no it's it's uh
it's so it's so crazy how you know the
different relationships
between different different countries
that you know are having to deal with
you know playing both sides or being a
part of a tug of war between country
different countries just because they're
stuck in the middle of these two
superpowers
like uh right you know right now with
russia and uh and the ukraine
yeah so crazy and america doesn't have
as much sway as it used to
um we're a lot more globalized now there
are other countries that have come up
um so like in the
when we were in the middle east so i've
never been to i've never actually been
to south asia but when we were in the
middle east we were close enough to
south asia so like india pakistan
um that we um we
met a lot of people from those areas
there and it was
fascinating to watch the relationship
there like america's not even like
barely a consideration
um you know uncertain things but i mean
really like they are dealing with their
neighbors like in the middle east and
south asia like they are dealing with
their immediate
neighbors because that like they have
nukes
right like that's who's going to affect
them you know and then there's always
the question of is america going to get
involved or not right like if
a country doesn't think that america is
going to back them up they have to start
thinking about their other options
so the further the more like
nationalists we become
the more everybody else like there's
going to there's a power vacuum that
happens
other people fill in you know there
can't be a vacuum
somebody's gonna fill in that spot and
the scariest part about it is too that
those countries are so like you said so
much more aggressive and they'll take
extreme measures like way harsher than i
feel like the united states would even
take
well because there's a history there i
mean think about how old the countries
you know i mean do we just we were
talking earlier about how young america
is like there's this
very long history in these regions
um you know so lots of baggage lots of
you know disputes that were you know are
still kind of festering
you know um you can see it when you read
about the border disputes in the area
lots of cultural issues um that
i think americans like we can't even
relate to
are you i was talking to uh to andy last
time about
how in some of the embassies in cuba and
russia the american embassies
they there were a lot of people in
different agencies like the cia and the
fbi that were experiencing like
crazy headaches yeah i read about that
and migraines and
experiencing disorders and because yeah
you know about this maybe you can
explain it better than i can
but basically they were like targeting
radiation towards these embassies that
we're giving people
yeah head injuries basically yeah so
there are certain countries that like to
play
dirty um so i still i i mean whatever
you think about the cia like america has
standards right we have lawyers
we have laws we have standards um you
know we have a democratic government
but there are other countries that do
not
foreign